Donna's Creed has been defined by boxing
his entire life
but it's boxing all adonises how do you
raise the bar for the man that we've
gotten to know throughout Creek one and
Creed 2. and really take his franchise
to the next level
in the Creed Three Adonis is a father a
husband a better man
but his secrets from his past his family
doesn't know
hey my man can I help you you don't
remember me huh
damn you
wanted to tell a story that honored the
legacy of Rocky but was different and a
big part of that was introducing Damien
Anderson how long were you locked up 18
Years bro I know I've been away a long
time but I still got gas in the tank
come by the gym
thank you
donate and Damien have a real past they
grew up as children together in a really
tough environment who cares what
happened with you too he was like
brothers I was the best though man I
never got a chance to prove that they
shared this box thing green together so
imagine what happens when you have to
watch someone live that dream without
you it can breed resentment Damien was
like family hey hey what you doing man
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find him
I had a Clear Vision of what I wanted
this story to be
I grew up with Adonis Creed so this
opportunity to direct their installment
it's so personal to me
getting to see my Approach directing and
almost athletic way was incredible to
watch good working with Mike it was a
real collaboration and when you feel
that trust it's the best gift an actor
can have
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people this is a movie that
lends itself to that big screen
experience
face the action if you want to see that
up close and personal I'm coming for
everything you threatening me
it's all on the line here
scared of death what you gonna do
threaten to take my breath
all roads led up to this moment and we
need to see what happens next